>> ♪ ♪
>> AS USUAL THE MEDIA BRINGS
NOTHING TO THE TABLE EXCEPT A
CHIP ON THEIR TABLE AND A HUNGER
FOR CHAOS.
LAST NIGHT THEY SAW THE FOG OF
WAR AS THE PERFECT TIME FOR
SOLEMN PRONOUNCEMENTS COURTESY
OF IRAN TELEVISION.
>> I AM NOT SURE ABOUT IRAN'S
STATE MEDIA IS CLAIMING THAT 30
U.S. SOLDIERS HAVE BEEN KILLED
IN THIS ATTACK.
THIS IS NOT CONFIRMED.
JUST COMING FROM IRANIAN MEDIA.
WE JUST STEPPED OVER THE
PRECIPICE.
>> HOW DID THAT GUY GET THAT
INFO SO FAST?
YOU CAN'T GET A BOX SCORE THAT
QUICKLY.
MAYBE THAT SHOULD HAVE TIPPED
HIM OFF.
NBC INVITES VIEWERS TO WATCH
LIVE COVERAGE OF SOLEIMANI'S
BURIAL.
MICHAEL MOORE LOWERED HIS BELLY
AT HALF MAST.
AND JOE TIES IT ALL BACK TO
RUSSIA.
>> IT WOULD BE HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT DONALD TRUMP WOULD LAUNCH
ATTACKS INTO IRAN WITHOUT
SPEAKING FIRST TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
THIS WOULD OBVIOUSLY LIE AT THE
HEART OF VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
INTEREST SINCE IRAN HAS BEEN
SEEN AS PUTIN AS A CLIENT STATE
OF RUSSIA.
>> WHAT ABOUT BUTT HEAD.
HE THINKS THIS PRESIDENT IS
IMPULLSIVE.
>> HE IS IMPULLSIVE AND DOESN'T
THINK THROUGH THE IMPLICATIONS
OF HIS ACTIONS.
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN A MASSIVE
CATASTROPHE.
>> HE IS LIKE A STOPPED CLOCK
WITH BRILL CREAM.
IMAGINE GOING TO THE MOVIES AND
FACING THE WRONG WAY IN YOUR
SEAT.
THAT'S THE MEDIA.
MISSING THE BIG PICTURE.
PERFERRING THE STORY THAT
MATCHES THE VOICES IN THEIR
HEAD.
THEY STILL CAN'T STOP.
>> WE ARE ONLY HERE AT THIS
MOMENT, THIS VERY DANGEROUS
MOMENT BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP'S
IMPULLSIVENESS.
>> THESE WORLD CHANGING AND
HISTORIC CALAMITYS.
>> IT'S THE EARLY STAGE OF A HOT
WAR.
>> THIS IS WHAT MANY FOREIGN
POLICY AND NATIONAL SECURITY
ANALYSTS FEARED IN WASHINGTON.
>> THIS COULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
EFFECT.
WE MAY BE ON A ROAD TO A
DIFFERENT MIDDLE EAST.
>> THIS IS A GRAVE AND SERIOUS
MOMENT.
>> YEP.
I AIN'T SAYING THIS IS NOT
SERIOUS.
BUT ALL OF THE SWEATY HYSTERICS
ARE WISHFUL THINKING.
DIAL IT BACK A LITTLE.
YOU ARE ALWAYS WRONG.
MAYBE WE ARE ON THE PRECIPICE OF
PEACE AND NOT WAR.
IT'S NOT OVER.
IT'S WEDNESDAY WHICH IS BETTER
THAN TUESDAY.
LAST NIGHT WAS ANOTHER CHANCE TO
SCARE THE CRAP OUT OF US.
THE APOCALYPSE IS EVERY DAY THAT
ENDS IN Y.
>> SHANNON, I THEN IS THE MEDIA.
THEY REPEAT WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
THEY DON'T SAY WOW, WE SCREWED
UP.
I NOTICE THAT.
WE THOUGHT THERE WAS WORLD WAR
III.
NO WAR BUT IT COULD HAPPEN
TODAY.
>> THE AYATOLLAH SAYS IT'S NOT
OVER.
WHEN THEY GET WHAT THEY WANT
FROM THE PRESIDENT, THEY SAID
THERE SHOULD NOT BE A RESPONSE.
HE GIVES A SPEECH WHICH WAS VERY
CALM SAYING WE WANT PEACE TO
HELP THE PEOPLE OF IRAQ.
THE "WASHINGTON POST," AN OP-ED
PIECE.
THEY CALLED IT A DERANGED
SPEECH.
THERE WAS NO ELOQUENCE.
FILLED WITH LIES AND GARBLED.
IT DIDN'T CONVINCE ANYONE.
HE WILL NEVER WIN OVER SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE.
>> I WATCHED CNN AT THE GYM
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT ON.
I SAW BARBARA STARR AND GLORIA
AND --
>> ON TELEVISION?
>> IT'S THE SAME OLD NAMES AND
FACES SAYING THE SAME OLD STUFF.
SHOULDN'T THERE BE QUALITY
CONTROL.
>> ALL THE WAY BACK TO WEAPONS
OF MASS DESTRUCTION?
>> YES.
>> THE MEDIA WENT ALONG.
>> WE WILL GO ALONG WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SURE.
THERE MUST BE WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
>> THEY ARE WRONG NOW.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S JOB IS TO BE
SKEPTICAL AND CHALLENGE US.
WHERE ARE THE FACTS THAT JUSTIFY
YOU GOING OUT AND SETTING OFF
WHAT COULD BEEN A TRAGIC
SITUATION?
WE ARE HAPPY TODAY THAT THINGS
HAVE GONE DOWN QUIETLY.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND, ONE
ERRANT MISSILES COULD BE A
TRAGEDY.
I DISAGREE WITH THE BUSINESS
ABOUT THE REPORTER.
REPORTERS IN IRAN WHERE THERE IS
NO FIRST AMENDMENT AND NO
PROTECTION.
IF YOU SAY THIS IS WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT -- WE CAN'T CONFIRM
IT.
>> 30 AMERICANS ARE DEAD?
THAT'S TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> TURN ON IRANIAN STATE TV.
>> HE ATTRIBUTED TO THE
IRANIAN --
>> AS A GUY IN THE FIELD FOR 40
YEARS, JUAN.
>> I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> IMAGINE IF YOU WERE IN NORTH
KOREA.
SOMETIMES EVEN A FOX REPORTER
HAS TO SAY SOMETHING BECAUSE
NORTH KOREA IS MONITORING IT.
>> THE IRANIANS ARE SAYING 30
ARE DEAD AND THE AMERICANS SAY
NONE.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC CAN MAKE A
DECISION.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THAT'S TRUE
OR NOT.
>> WELL, NOW WE KNOW.
>> BUT THEN WE DIDN'T.
>> RIGHT.
>> CHRISTOPHER HAYES SAID THE
WAR IN IRAN IS A DISASTER IN THE
MAKING.
DON'T BELIEVE ANYONE WHO TELLS
US OTHERWISE.
DONALD TRUMP WAGGED THE DOG AND
NOW THE DOG IS WAGGING TRUMP?
REALLY BY HITTING THE MIDDLE OF
AN EMPTY BASE?
>> THE PRESS SAID IT COULD HAVE
BEEN AIL BENGHAZI.
THEN THEY FIND OUT IT'S NOT
THAT.
THEN THEY CONTINUE ON AND
CRITICIZE HIM WHEN HE TAKES
ACTION TO PROTECT AMERICANS.
JUAN, THEY TEACH YOU IN JOURNAL
SCHOOL NOT TO REPEAT GOVERNMENT
PROPAGANDA AND HOW THE MEDIA IN
THESE COUNTRIES IS RUN BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
YOU SHOULD NOT GLORIFY ANYTHING
THEY SAY AS FACT.
IT REALLY UNDERMINES THEIR
CREDIBILITY.
>> OH, THERE IS ANOTHER SHOOTER
OUT THERE AND THERE NEVER IS.
THEY CAN'T WAIT.
>> THE CREDIBILITY, THE PERSON'S
CREDIBILITY WHO IS UNDERMINED
HERE IS IRAN'S.
YOU HAVE TO REPORT.
IN A BREAKING NEWS SITUATION,
YOU ARE TRYING TO CONTROL WHAT
YOU CAN.
HE ATTRIBUTEED IT PROPERLY TO
THE IRANIAN GOVERNMENT.
>> WE THANK OUR REPORTERS OUT
THERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> AND THIS STORY TURNS THE
PRESIDENT'S DIRECTION WHEN THEY
TALK ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.